[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo las teorías conspirativas
alrededor de las vacunas han existido
durante décadas pero éstas se han
multiplicado durante el último año desde
que la comunidad científica se encaminó
a crear un antídoto contra el kobe 19
ahora que la vacunación empezó en varios
países nuevas noticias falsas han
empezado a surgir no solo para
atemorizar a las personas sino también
para estafarlas en esta oportunidad
desmentimos la desinformación frente al
tema empezamos uno de nuestros capítulos
anteriores estuvo dedicado a desmentir
la falsa relación entre las vacunas y el
autismo la homosexualidad la
esterilización y hasta la descabellada
idea de supuestos microchips implantados
por medio de las jeringas ahora que las
campañas de vacunación son un hecho este
tipo de noticias falsas son aún más
recurrentes en internet basta con
escribir la palabra vacuna en el
buscador de aplicaciones como telegram
para que aparezca una lista de canales
antivacunas cargados definidos observen
por ejemplo esta imagen que circula en
país
chile una supuesta lista de 26 efectos
secundarios de la vacuna contra el cob y
19 entre los que se encuentran parálisis
facial meningitis accidente
cerebrovascular artritis y hasta la
muerte la imagen es muy parecida a esta
la cual viene circulando en redes
sociales desde diciembre la falta de
credibilidad de este documento se puede
evidenciar en los errores ortográficos
por ejemplo no hay tildes en las
palabras comunes como página síndrome y
espontáneo
por otro lado la imagen hace referencia
a la fe de la administración de
medicamentos y alimentos de eeuu
menciona además que hay un documento en
el sitio web de dicha agencia que
enumera estas posibles reacciones
provocadas por la vacuna de la
farmacéutica pfiezer pero esta
información es completamente falsa el
documento citado por esta publicación no
es más que un borrador con fecha de
octubre de 2020 a través del cual la de
fedea hizo una lista provisional sobre
los posibles resultados adversos que
pudieran provocar todas las candidatas a
vacuna allí tampoco se menciona a facer
para entonces ningún antídoto había sido
aprobado por las autoridades de eeuu los
efectos secundarios que si podrían
producirse con la vacuna de esta
compañía son dolor en el lugar de la
inyección cansancio dolor de cabeza
entre otros y están publicados en la
página web de la rda
ahora es cierto que las nuevas variantes
de kobe 19 que se propagan en el mundo
fueron causadas por las vacunas esto es
totalmente falso en internet se dice
específicamente y sin ningún fundamento
que la vacuna de facer provocó la
mutación descubierta en reinounido el
primer caso de esta nueva variante se
identificó el 20 de septiembre de 2020
en territorio británico y el antídoto de
facer sólo empezó a ser administrado
hasta el 8 de diciembre más de dos meses
después la variante brasileña se reportó
a mitades de dinero pero la vacunación
allí empezó sólo hasta el 19 de enero
las autoridades sudafricanas reportaron
a mitades de diciembre la aparición de
una nueva variante en su territorio pero
sólo hasta ahora anunciaron que esperan
iniciar su plan de vacunación pronto
en 'facebook' 'twitter' y tick tock por
ejemplo circulan vídeos en los que se
denuncia que las campañas de vacunación
son un fraude porque no se debe salir en
ninguna aguja del brazo del paciente
cuando a éste se le aplica el antídoto
otros señalan que la aguja se está
rompiendo dentro del brazo de los
pacientes generando pánico entre la
población las denuncias corresponden a
este vídeo que ven en pantalla en el que
la punta de la inyección deja de verse
una vez que la vacuna es aplicada en
realidad se trata de una aguja retráctil
que se retrae en el cilindro de la
jeringa de esta manera se impide su
reutilización y la organización mundial
de la salud la recomienda como una forma
de reducir la propagación de
enfermedades de transmisión sanguínea
como el vih
puedo comprar la vacuna contra el kobe
19 por internet falso la desinformación
que desacredita la efectividad de las
vacunas no es el único problema que
enfrentan los gobiernos en internet
también se mueven anuncios que ofrecen
fraudulentos antídotos contra el virus
en países como brasil colombia y méxico
las autoridades han identificado sitios
web donde se comercializan este tipo de
productos sin licencias y en ecuador por
ejemplo han cerrado establecimientos
donde se aplican estas falsas vacunas
las autoridades de cada país han
advertido que estas sustancias podrían
ser un peligro para su salud y que sólo
los gobiernos han sido los encargados de
importar los antídotos por lo que son
los únicos autorizados para
distribuirlos y además lo están haciendo
de manera gratuita
los medios de comunicación han abordado
los problemas que enfrentarán los
gobiernos para lograr su objetivo de
inmunizar a su población portafolio de
colombia titula que acabar con los mitos
es la otra tarea de la vacunación contra
el cob y el comercio de ecuador dice que
la existencia de diferentes vacunas ha
sembrado dudas entre la población
relacionadas principalmente con su
eficacia y seguridad y con el proceso
seguido para su autorización un artículo
de la edición mexicana de la revista
forbes insta a que la utilización de las
vacunas tiene que ser acompañada de una
narrativa pedagógica que resuelva dudas
y entierre prejuicios
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerda
que si quieres repetir esta u otra
misión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
puntos 24 punto com
[Música]